[Music]
in our modern culture people like to
play a game of victimhood and oppression
and persecution it seems that everyone
has a persecution complex these days
virtually none of them have ever faced
any legitimate persecution or suffering
in their lives there is an objective
answer though to which groups are more
and less persecuted than others legally
socially violently and it is simply a
fact born out by all survey data and all
of history that Christians are the most
persecuted group in the world ironically
this is the group that we are told is
the least persecuted of all I'm so
pleased to be joined by my friend Father
Benedict key the leader of nazaran .org
n a n.org there are some other groups
that have different names I think one of
which is led by our friend glenbeck uh
nazarene.org father Kea you''ve visited
uh Iraq something like nine times and uh
you've you've written and been very
focused on and dedicated shrines to
persecuted Christians in the Middle East
last time we spoke we talked about what
was going on in Armenia uh we've talked
about what was going on in the Levant
since I last saw you I'm sorry to say
there was a terrible attack on
Christians on Christmas day in Nigeria
and yet the media have barely talked
about it strangely thank you again
Michael for having me strangely we're
told and rightly so black lives matter
but apparently black Christian lives
black Nigerian lives don't matter at all
uh in the year 2021 to
2022 uh more than
7,000 Nigerian Christians were martyred
men women and children over Christmas at
least 200 Christians were martyred
martyred being the operative word they
were murdered because they were
Christians they were murdered in
churches uh churches burnt down not
covered in the media at all if covered I
remember when I was on your show before
we spoke about a previous occasion when
it's alleged that it's this happens
because of climate change uh but nothing
it's nothing to do with climate change
they're being the Christians are being
attacked by islamists but it's not just
Nigeria it's exponential across Africa
the persecution of Christians it is the
almost the epicenter now of Christian
persecution uh not covered by the media
at all except by you so when thank you
very much and uh I'm so pleased we have
this opportunity because as people might
understand from your accent you're not
originally from Tennessee it's more was
it Kentucky or Alabama Perhaps Perhaps
people spoke like this maybe two or 3
hundred years ago it it's changed since
then uh but you go all over the world
and uh you know call attention to
this when did Africa become the
epicenter of persecution of Christians
well if we want to be historical we can
go back uh maybe 17 or 1800 years we
think of the great Martyrs of Africa but
no this has all happened in with the
rise of Islamic fundamentalism over the
last 10 15 years or so it's been growing
and growing uh sponsored in the past by
Saudi Arabian and the wahhabist uh and
Isis is very large in Africa under
different names uh we we've heard before
about the the death of Isis the defeat
of Isis the caliphate was defeated in
Iraq but not Isis Isis is very large in
Africa different groups Isis in
subsaharan Africa they have names like
that and they are sweeping across Africa
being AR armed by uh different countries
uh it's very very very serious uh and
it's a threat to actually the stability
of Africa which is why I would imagine
Western governments would be interested
but they seem to be pulling out in fact
France has just pulled out of uh I think
Chad and Mali the Hungarian government
interestingly enough is actually sending
some troops to to uh Chad and Mari uh
the Hungarian government is I always do
a little plug for the hungarians even
though they're not very popular and some
the Hungarian government is the only
government in the entire world that has
a specific government Ministry for
persecuted Christians it's actually
called the state Secretariat for
persecuted Christians not the state
Secretariat for diversity or inclusivity
or various rights it's called the state
Secretariat for persecuted Christians
and they've been working since
2016 the only government in the world
to help persecuted Christians so I
always have to give them a little plug
cuz they're doing such good work last
time when we spoke about the ngoro
carabat conflict of The
aeran attacking the Armenian Christians
oldest Christian nation in the world I
discussed it on the show and I said I I
think we the United States has some
interest here in protecting Armenia from
just a pure real politique standpoint
but also from a matter of Christian
solidarity If We Are the World Police if
we are the global Empire and the
Undisputed for now hegemon uh then we're
a Christian Nation and they're a
Christian Nation and we ought to have a
little bit of solidarity and I was
assailed from all sides for suggesting
one that America is a Christian Nation
and two that we ought to have solidarity
with Christians at all forget in
particular at all whatsoever this
strikes me as very very strange and I I
can't quite tell when it began that we
would intentionally neglect
our fellow members of the body of Christ
the faith that built the civilization
Christians would believe that but I I
fear unfortunately I can see why you
were ailed
perhaps in the first instance because we
know that the present Administration
this is not being party political
unfortunately it's it's a reality the
previous administration we won't mention
the name uh but the previous
administration was extremely positive
towards uh persecuted Christians large
amounts of help literally I know this as
a fact on the day that the present
Administration took over for example a
very large amount of money was due to go
to Nigeria Nigeria itself to help
persecute Christians that was stopped
immediately all Aid basically to
persecuted Christians across the world
this was a policy decision I was in Iraq
in uh
2016 17 uh right before the election one
of of the it was almost a joke we were
asking people in the in the camps who
who would you like to be the president
of the United States and everyone will
Trump we love Trump everyone we in fact
filmed it and a friend sent it to the to
to the to the president um uh and they
said because this the Biden
administration had done nothing but this
President Administration sorry the Obama
Administration this present
Administration has made a policy
decision
apparently uh Christians are um a
non-tolerated group if they someone poor
individual transsexual that had a a bad
hair day in Kazakhstan there would have
been probably a a debate at the United
Nations you'd have a whole delegation M
money would flow in but uh no thousands
and thousands but also sadly where we
are talking about rail politic you talk
about aaban aaban has oil
um Nigeria has vast amounts of oil when
you're dealing with trade trade and Aid
I always say we can make a difference if
we actually bring up trade and Aid in
terms of helping people who are being
persecuted if governments had some moral
uh strength some moral probity um
intestinal fortitude perhaps Christian
intestinal fortitude they would say
until tell you if you if you stop
persecuting Christians then we will
trade with you if not but that's never
part of the deal
if you have nothing I suppose then maybe
they can do some work with them but
these places have oil that's one of the
big
thing I have no problem in principle
with the United States being involved
around the world in fact it seems to me
that great Nations always are involved
around the world and even midsize and
not so great nations are involved around
the world because man is a social
creature but there are a lot of
conservatives who say enough we're we're
funding the whole world we're rich Uncle
Penny bags here and we don't really know
what what our interests are and it's
ridiculous and we want to just focus on
the home front and I I wonder how much
of that is because foreign aid and and
even Wars of intervention today are
focused on raising a pride flag in
Kandahar which I have no interest in
doing I don't want my tax dollars to do
it I don't want a single US soldier to
be put In Harm's Way for that dubious
goal if however we're discussing real
questions of American interest Western
interest and solid ity with our fellow
Christians around the world that would
seem like the the sort of involvement
that
would interest many many more Americans
who are skeptical of American
intervention we're looking at what the
great Cardinal Sarah from Africa called
a new form of colonialism that the the
Western ideology the
lgbtq multiple letters ideology is being
pushed on Africa Aid will only come if
if they and they say we don't want this
this is a new form of colonialism uh
again it's also not necessarily about
putting troops I can understand that
putting troops on the ground caused half
this problem back in in 2003 certainly
for the Middle East and in other places
but it is well either back to your
earlier question either America is a
Christian Nation or not if though sadly
it appears that more and more people
especially younger people in the west
are beginning to hate their own Heritage
uh then then they're not going to be
supporting this and let's be honest
Michael um a lot of people see the
church as the enemy ultimately because
of issues like human sexuality we are we
are bigots so why support bigots in
another country why why help them they
probably deserve it I was actually told
I was told by a journalist um from a
very senior
organization that Christians deserved
what they were getting in these
countries it was quite an extraordinary
moment to be told that um that's what
we're dealing with we're dealing with
that kind of ideology that's not just in
the media but as we know is in Academia
and in in government you you mentioned
Cardinal Sarah uh who many American and
Western Conservative Catholics just
adore and uh he's certainly more
conservative than other Bishops and
Cardinals these days and a wonderful
defender of the faith he wrote a book
with the late Pope Benedict the and
anyway he's just a great guy I can't
help but notice that even as the
European and many American Bishops seem
to embrace or accidentally Embrace or
just all sorts of crazy things modern
sexuality and the global warming stuff
and mass migration and things that
really have no place in the Catholic
tradition it is the African Bishops and
the African Cardinals who are standing
up against
that I how did we come to that situation
well the family is still in tact in
Africa I think this is where if you want
to get down to the essentials we know in
the west it's it's the attack on the
family has been it's that's almost the
epicenter of of of the ideology and as
the family has been destroyed and
alternative visions of the family have
been created but in Africa the family
and The Wider family is still very
strong and so a seeming
attack blessed by the church on the
family and the institution of the family
is being resisted and we have to say God
bless them because uh maybe they will be
the saviors of of of of Western
Christianity in the end we we know in
America and and in in Europe we have
many priests now from Africa uh and they
were so it's because well we we brought
the gospel to them so they brought the
gospel back to us but no actually
they're obviously they're coming because
we haven't got enough priests but they
usually preach uh with some force and
some Vigor and um usually they can't be
attacked because of their skin color
which is rather helpful so so no God
bless the Africans I I'm I'm very
encouraged by what what's been happening
I meant I I read some really depressing
statistics the other day on not just how
modern people think about the family and
sexuality and everything you just
mentioned but how Catholics view
it most American Catholics support
contraception most American Catholics
support so-called same-sex marriage most
American Catholics
reject the perennial teaching of the
Catholic Church on on matters that get
to the very core of the human person and
the fundamental political
institution and not even small numbers
we're talking like 69% 89% in some cases
support these
things one how how how do you reconcile
that apparent contradiction and two is
there any hope to do anything about it
most American Catholics are not well
catechized as are most English Catholics
as are most European I'm 60 years old my
generation or before me down now three
generations Pope Benedict himself said
have not were not catechized so it's no
surprise uh that is there hope yes I
think there's great hope because the
younger generation certainly especially
in the United States coming out of some
of these great Catholic colleges
Stubenville Christendom Ivan muia are
producing really wonderful young people
who love the church for all its faults
uh who want to have marriages want to
have lots of children it it's a great
hope we just have to go through uh the
winter of discontent as we might say and
a rather aging clergy who still think
that uh flared trousers are the latest
rage once they depart then we younger
priests are tending to be more I don't
like the use of the word
conservative or political I use
heterodox or Orthodox Orthodox priests
who believe in the teaching of the
church um and happy being happy
Catholics um not happy C clappy
Catholics but happy Catholics who who
love the faith um we're in a very hard
time and you know as a Layman I know as
a priest it's an extremely hard time
when the leadership of the church um I'm
reminded of Bello's quote about IM
basilic and naves but um uh no no merely
Human Institution conducted with such
navish imbecility would have lasted aord
exactly and there are a few of them
around at the moment and we have to get
through this but we have to hold on and
be happy and love our faith and and be
joyful H and and I think there's great
hope uh but at the moment the ship is I
I think of a a friend of mine who was
who was received into the church last
year and I preached at her reception
quoting Cardinal Newman and John Henry
Newman who said when he became a
Catholic that he felt like he was a ship
coming into Port after a heavy storm and
I said to her uh you're going out of the
port Into the Storm now becoming a
Catholic so it's rather exciting
actually that people are still becoming
Catholic when you think what on Earth
are you doing that for you know I I see
it especially among young people uh a
lot of people returning to religion in
any form and specifically to
Christianity and specifically to
Catholicism and you're you're seeing a
vibrant intellectual movement it it's uh
wonderful and yet the people who run the
society uh seem to be moving in the
other direction you're seeing a big push
to persecute Christians violently in
some cases just legally you know in the
United States and Canada America's evil
top hat and uh you're seeing a
push to break up the family and to
question what a human person is and to
meld us with robots and to live forever
and this is what's so strange about it
is the way that they speak they they
sound like they're seeking religious
goals when they say man is going to
cease to be Homo sapiens he's going to
be homod Deus we are going to cure death
we're going to live forever we're we're
going to be immortal we're going to have
Fame our Legacy will live on and these
are people who don't get married don't
have children don't dogs though they do
they have dogs they do have dogs two of
them even that's right sometimes in in a
stroller a carrier they love that but I
think well the easiest way for you to
have a legacy and to have immortality
way easiest way to have immortality is
to know God and love him and you know
God sent his only begotten son so that
whoever believes in him might not perish
but have everlasting life that's a good
good way to do it and the easiest way to
have a legacy is to have children and
have a lot of them and then you have a
living Legacy and the very thing that
would give them what they seek they do
the opposite of I remember reading an
interview with the I'm pushing Hungary
again but the president of Hungary
catalyst Novak is a wonderful woman
Hungary has a great policy of helping
families now no no income tax after
three children and imagine if a
politician here ran with that you won't
pay income tax if you have more than
three children sign me up but president
Novak said at one point last year
because people are saying oh don't have
children for the environment and she
said well who's it for then in 100 years
is it is it for the apes or the ants or
something it's for our children but
actually you hit to be more serious
though you hit something essential we
are and I think we have to use the word
I read a marvelous article recently by a
man called Mark douly who is a
philosopher he actually is the uh great
expert on S Roger scrutin and but he
wrote a piece uh in the European
conservative last fall basically saying
we talk about a culture
War he said that implies there are two
cultures he said uh and I think it's
really profound he said no there are not
two cultures there's one culture
the culture of the West a culture from a
culus worship he said it's about Good
and Evil and we've got to actually draw
this conclusion and speak the truth in
love it's about Good and Evil it's not
calling the people themselves evil but
the philosophy that's being promoted you
were talking about melding humans and
machines the attack on the personhood
the attack on children that you can be
whatever you want to be no you can't be
he actually said it it's sort of reverse
of being all things in Christ you can
create yourself the attack on children
the the sexualization of children the
attack on the family he said we must
call it what it is this is evil and I
know people will respond sometimes with
horror how how can you Christians say
that but no it's a fight now it's it's
really uh we we spoke before about
picking a side actually we've really got
to be honest one side or the other and
that it's a battle St Paul spoke about
it it's about uh spiritual realities
powers and principalities and evil is
very active in the world today so we
better be armed with as scripture says
all the the weapons of faith I love the
idea of picking a side because if you
stand in the middle of the road you will
be hit by a truck well the sitting on
the fence is also rather
uncomfortable it is you're right father
key thank you so much as always for
coming in and I look forward to the next
time that we can drag you back from that
Island over there to Tennessee thank you
[Music]
Michael